Reggie Miller and c-webb joining us here
the movie tonight now it's released
nationally on Friday and uncle drew with
Reggie c-webb Kyrie Shaq Nate Robinson
and Lisa Leslie and the world premiere
tonight here in New York City we were
just talking before we came back on
about James Harden and I joke about it I
would have music every every arena he
went into I'd like you know walking on
sunshine and travel walk on the wild
side yeah okay you guys have talked
about it now what did the league do
league-wide about James Harden and is
there traveling with that signature move
that he has that step-back move yeah
most of the time he steps back is
traveling sometimes he stepped back
isn't traveling he does have the best
year-old step which I think confuses
everything because he and Ginobili are
the best real steps that we've seen but
they sent out of tape saying that this
is not traveling it is not a trial and
we were surprised but I mean I guess
they claim the territory
early we're not we can't make him change
it he's a great player get used to this
new move so the league was probably
tired of hearing from everybody
everyone's probably complaining because
it does and in my opinion I don't mind
the step back but it's the bunny hop
after the step back to me you you're
gaining an unfair advantage to me that's
traveling did you guys know how good he
was in Oklahoma City you know then I
think that's when I started to really
get my chops as a commentator because I
didn't realize why the whole world was
mad at me because I was I guess I was
being politically incorrect saying OKC
is making the dumbest move ever they
should not do this
this guy leads he was leading the league
in assists in the fourth quarter and he
was coming off the bench being the sixth
man so I can't say I knew he was MVP
status but I knew he was somebody that
you do not trade from these two players
because with Westbrook and Durant he was
uh he was like the equalizer
he kept everybody involved he wasn't
trying to score too much he would keep
Westbrook involved keep the ball out of
Westbrook same the time and even get
hooked Durant up so yeah I knew it was
I thought it was one of the most
terrible moves ever and it was for
Andrew Bynum it was to get Perkins for
Andrew Bynum that's all I can you gotta
worry about that was dumb an elk bill I
mean they're gonna continue to regret
that whether Westbrook stays or not
that's gonna haunt them but you look
back if Oklahoma City had kept James
Harden and and let Westbrook go what
Durant's still be in Oklahoma City no
they didn't have to let whisperer go
well just I think you did just for the
the you know Westbrook dominates the
ball no no but they all love playing
together see remember what this is Arden
did not want to take that leadership
role if we remember whether it was Kevin
McHale Sandro other player Santa he was
happy in that role of coming off the
bench that's why I was like you have to
keep it and you see their relationship
so I don't think it was one of the other
now if he would have kept them you know
personalities maybe I don't know if he
would have grown though to the I mean he
was always a gifted scorer would he had
become what he has no we wouldn't battle
thing but you're saying that the so
Durant like playing with Westbrook he'd
like playing with Hartley oh okay well
that's why I'm saying Harden then I keep
Turan we do keep Harden both of them
would have been happy because you have a
balanced system yeah
has there ever been a franchise or a
team that's had three MVPs think about
this I mean Kevin Durant won MVP
obviously Westbrook last year was in VP
and then this year harden when it wins
it this is a team that went to the
finals obviously they were younger
versus the Cavs in LeBron but what if
what if they would have stayed together
and they would have had a chance to kind
of grow up together could that have been
the dynasty that people were talking
about well if you had let's say at
golden stage three without Durant
but you had Durant Westbrook and Harden
that's your super you like OKC better
than you would golden state right
without hard they had him but imagine if
they beat him does Durant stay in
Oklahoma City yes I don't think he stays
in Oklahoma City but he's certainly not
going to Golden State I think he stays
because
he wins it and if you win one there in
that small market I just don't see you
know how you can go like where's Ruth at
17 years in 18 18 years and in the end I
think they would have seen the other
side to it that hey we did win one here
we can have our career separately in the
summers live other places but I think he
would have a blessing in disguise to
lose is your golden stage yeah that was
a blessing in disguise because you got
Kevin Durant we were also talking about
this prior to the show and and we go
back to the fab 5 that maybe you guys
built the first super team because Juwan
Howard was I think the first guy in at
Michigan and then he recruited you guys
so he's building a super team full of
freshmen and I don't know if we've ever
had that before with with a super team
yeah that's that's a great point because
we were friends but I almost went to
Duke because Grant Hill you know it was
a lot of at that time your friends being
the one to say hey man we can do this
forget about oh my god you almost went
to Duke oh yeah yeah oh I mean if you
ask coach ko time is upon me things
happen but I really almost went to Duke
Michigan was 30 minutes away from the
front door to to the dorm and look what
happened Juwanna
you know I'm the oldest of five my
parents you know staying home a family
of the oldest you want to you know be
there I love Michigan you know and so
but it was it was funny because Juwan ID
funny story I mention want a nightcap oh
god this funny story yeah big mooks
shaving is he
I just remember being Kuhlman you know
he was the one saying I think Illinois
was on probation that year or he was
definitely easy he's a Chicago guy yeah
and he was like listen man Michigan
sucks last year they only won like 12
games they're terrible we don't have a
lot of it he's like I'll have people
he's like man you know what if we all go
we might be able to start he was he was
a big big reason that along with I grew
up with Jaylin
I knew Hema Detroit the whole time and
and then I kind of got close with Ray as
well laughs okay so how close was he
gonna be Duke and then Michigan State no
I was gonna be Michigan State first okay
I thought I was going to Michigan State
from growing up my whole life being
imagine right now you feel friends
telling people in Michigan right now so
told us two years ago he still bothered
by left by that we lost you you know how
he I consider time a very close friend
and it's from all those years of getting
to know each other you know I saw him
under coach Heathcote I saw the program
he was building I saw his intensity and
I got to know him on a level before he
was a head coach that I'll always
respect so he and his wife I love them
but uh yeah almost almost when you could
have done is oh you could have done
Coach K we're see Grant Hill Susanoo
Grant Hill says oh I was like 11 he and
I were very close to June along with
Laettner first of all Duke was and it's
funny I think I saw gold first of all I
saw this documentary I hate Duke was by
far my best visit you know where they
took me they took me like to the black
college like down the street North
Carolina
see you and I go with Kristen lately
like on a Monday like the first of all
they don't know conditioning this is how
you recruiting conditioning they just
played their way in that's all the
players say like man we don't have
conditioning you have good practices no
condition you that's when we were
tracking everything and he's like look
we have all these universities around
and they just use the best parties ever
that that that Grant Hill and I give
late no more credit he showed me a great
time look maybe you got along with later
yeah I mean if there's on the court we
didn't like you know but I'm really good
at you know keeping it on the court or
not and you know so separating yeah but
he's uh I mean in my opinion Christian
Laettner is you know in my generation
he's the best college player several
Asian oh yeah period
yeah I mean he he came a big yeah and he
was consistent those four years and he
really changed the game as far as where
he was shooting the reason and having
the ball on the post and passing the
things that Coach K did for him to allow
his game to flourish really help big
fellows like myself NES swag okay so Jim
Harbaugh calls you and says he wants you
to go tell me how this happens that Jim
Harbaugh is inviting Chris Webber back
to Michigan when's the last time you've
been back to Michigan uh out of cousins
graduation and he's up there was while
ago I talked to coach Harbaugh a couple
times everything were you ain't
comfortable with the graduation oh I'm
uncomfortable in large cities when we're
celebrating family members because I
don't want to I don't want my presence
to you know show up with there but being
on campus didn't make you uncomfortable
no okay no but you haven't you hadn't
been back basketball wise no have you
been invited back basket yeah but so
let's go back from the beginning so like
years after the NBA I've never gone back
you know like after I call the timeout
and everything then I was on a mission
to try to right every wrong you know you
want to win a championship you want to
play so it never was a thing oh I'm not
going back it was like I got business to
do and we're not
come back holding his trophy I got you
you know that type of thing and didn't
get a trophy thanks to Shaq and a couple
of his zebra stripe so that was that was
a little bit tough so no I hadn't been
back and then you know just all the
controversy and things and really then
with the controversy it's like you need
time to sit down and talk about I never
want to do like a five minute interview
take the snippet from that and let that
define it when there's so much to talk
about so with that I never really felt I
never really felt any type of way
truthfully so the last few years when
coach Harbaugh got the job if you
remember coach Harbaugh wanted the job
at Michigan before and he went to
Stanford and we had a little bit of a
kindred spirit time then because we both
known both schambach we both have had
intimate conversations with him we both
know Michigan man he wanted to be there
took down all these jerseys and all this
stuff and they brought him back called
him to congratulate him every year I'm a
big fan hey coach how are we doing this
year so he's asking me three years maybe
in a row to come back and I said coach I
don't think this is the right time coach
I don't think this is the right time I
love the University I'll be back I don't
think this is the right time so the
other day we were doing a charity
Michigan from the heart and it's a
charity register we did a Michigan where
they take the athletes and you go to the
children's hospitals and you work with
the kids and it really changed you know
my life at the time we had this kid
Randy other kids that may be only
supposed to be with us for a little
while and we made them part of the team
and just you know the inspiration they
gave us and so we were on this show
talking about all the good times with
Jamie Morris ex-football player or not I
was doing the Jamie a favor and want the
help for the charity I hadn't spoken in
awhile and coach Harbaugh knew I was on
there and he called in again and asked
and I give him a lot a lot of credit for
because he could have gone bad on the
radio you know or you know and I thanked
him for asking me and I definitely want
to show up and I want to
I'm awesome do you know what game yet I
don't but I think I do but I'm you know
you got to picked up you got to pick the
best at Ohio State Michigan State nabis
Penn State it's a couple games there's a
good game no we don't have any other
games but some of those guys are gonna
travel and go to you know I have a
friend that played at Ohio State so we
go to game sneak in the games all the
time and so I think it may be the Penn
State game but I'm not sure but I tell
you this Denham
I pulled out my varsity jacket my father
he had sauce my father has everything
you know he still trophies and stuff
he'll know where it's at so you still
have your Michigan varsity varsity sport
don't we okay Bobby take a break more
with Chris Weber and Reggie Miller the
movie is uncle drew premiere tonight
we're not walking the red carpet by the
way reg just show up yeah we will
okay I mean that's all I did when I
played I just showed up you really think
it doesn't matter you're gonna be there
I'm gonna go I'm sitting next to you but
I'm not doing red carpet because then
it'll be awkward where we'll walk and
then they'll want to talk to you and
then I told you say something to you if
maybe to you I don't know about all the
damage yeah pretty I just got a note
from PR saying the Wilco actually means
they will call us
hi table we'll be back more with Chris
Weber and Reggie Miller right after this
15 after the hour Dan Patrick show four
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]